a big thank you to aa and ufc 4 for
sponsoring today's video there you go
yeah
me and the lads are always playing this
in the studio and as you can imagine
it's a good way to settle some sort of
personal grudges that develop when
you're working alongside lawrence
mckenna to celebrate the ufc coming back
to london ufc 4 has dropped a huge
update including some of the best
british fighters this will include paddy
the body paul craig tom hospital and of
course today's guest on the podcast
molly mccann all for the first time
representing the uk in ufc 4. this
update is released today so as you're
watching this you can also be
downloading updating doing the thing to
get in the cage and go you alright la
scousers we don't get knocked out you
can do all that right now while
listening to this podcast so it's a
no-brainer getting the game guys so log
in now to your console and get the ufc 4
uk fighter pack and play as all of your
faves while listening to this bloody
good podcast you've not heard it yet but
just trust me it's really good this one
if you haven't got the game don't worry
i've got you covered with a discount you
can click the link in the description
below and get up to eighty percent off
to get your copy of the game and then
you can have it all
it would have worked better without the
dishwasher but this is uh annoying but
paddy the bad news it's a limited time
offer so get your clicks in the
description while you can just saying
but for now it's molly mccann on the
pain game podcast this woman say that
what a ledge
[Music]
at one time i was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence i'm
scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make a comeback
fighting this was designed for me and
what makes us who we are
i'm so far ahead of this game
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
i have always been a fighter there's
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a map like that
to me i
[Music]
welcome back to the pain game podcast
today's guest could be described as
the baddest woman in britain but that
sounds a bit like a netflix documentary
doesn't it it's a bit but um
molly pleasure to have you on the show
thanks i'm really sorry little frank box
lads get to bed no it's all good it's
all good
i'm a dog lover i'm a dog lover that's
all good we're excited today because
obviously you've just entered the ufc
game i've got my copy don't know if
you've got uh if you've got
it do you see that have you made that
for me
no no you have seated seeing that
look at you
what
yeah i can't even scream she's got this
huh i'll i'll send you uh i'll send you
a picture
i love the fact that i've got a copy
before you
[Laughter]
is it usg4 still yeah yeah it's the new
one it's the ufc four yeah so uh that's
you in the game the queen of the ring or
the cage roller that's unreal isn't it
yeah oh i've made it onto the front of
the game there you go
you're officially a superstar now that's
it well i said to paddy there's a few
things on me bucket list
whale champ
being in a game
being on a mural in liverpool and i feel
like i'm just slowly starting to take
them off so i'm pretty sure all of those
are on the cards like at this rate i can
see it
this is your year to be honest with you
like this is this is the year of uh
molly mccann it's uh it's been amazing
it's like it kind of reminds me a little
bit of mas vidal when he had that yeah
where he turned it all around and all of
a sudden it all came together and
obviously it culminated in your last
ufc event where
what a knockout i mean that is not out
of the year
there's been a few closed contenders but
i don't think anyone slept their
opponents as much as what i did no you
and the way you lined her up and then
span around and you know uh the arena
erupted and you sort of set the table
for uh paddy and aspinol like you you
took it up a level and then the crowd
were like okay this is this is it now
this is going to be the best event we've
seen the uk and um how does it feel to
get to that point where you are having
that yes i am here to stay this isn't
going to be taken away from me which i
feel like was a bit of a worry early on
in your career yeah i feel like when i
stepped into the ufc it was a bit too
much too soon during me and i'd had nine
fights
including me amateur fights and was on
the biggest stage and i had to do a lot
of growing in the ground on the floor in
front of everyone and sometimes it
didn't go so well but i laid a lot i
learned a lot in those lessons and in
those fights but
in september when me and paddy both got
the 50 grand bonuses
i fought now i've arrived and then
at ufc london i felt like the pressure
was more on patrick than anyone else
even more than tommy even more than
pardon me arnold allen so i thought when
i go out just get the crowd going like
if you've seen me posts every week it
was just the fans this is for you the
fans this is for you that walk out i
walked out to a jamie webster song
called this place which is all about
liverpool unless he's screamed to the
top of my lungs my people my city my
heart i just went in there and a fourth
as long as i give what i'm capable of
giving
then that's enough and and what no one
knows is well just before new year's eve
i fell over and i wasn't even drunk i
dislocated michelle then i told me
perhaps i'm a sprained mistain them like
my ac joint so
i couldn't throw a punch for six weeks
so it was only the last four weeks or
three weeks before the fight i was
actually able to start a punch
so i had the best performance of my life
when my body was the worst they could
have ever been
um and after that last fight even though
i've kind of blew up again
um
i've been doing so much strength and
conditioning and weight and if you can
imagine i couldn't squat for about six
months because i couldn't put nothing on
my shoulders and my little legs are like
this now ready to comfortably hannah
goldie in july you can see there's been
a bit of a body transformation as well
from your first performance in the ufc
you look like an athlete now is that
been a conscious thing where you've
really knuckled down if you look at me
and party me and patrick we're two kids
from the city who've got to the head of
the game of heart if you'd imagine my
coach paul where is face cropper faces
um from from the beginning so
as a as a group and as a collective
we've all leaned on the job and
and sometimes i've got it wrong
sometimes they've got it wrong sometimes
paddy's got it wrong but we've all
levelled up in terms of like
professionalism and
um out of camp i love bevy and paddy
loves to scrun but like when we're in
camp we're like buddhist monks and
and even out of camp we still train
every day you know what i mean but
nutrition
weight making i feel me body for
performance enough to make weight if
that makes sense
so whereas before
i would just be like oh i'm on a wake-up
from the day and started camp
now my cousin doesn't start till two
weeks before the fight so i can have
eight to ten weeks eaten responsibly and
periodized me food like me
man and paddy's nutritionist we're all
in this like little group on our we've
been so he's lost every day he's
watching and he's like you have not
enough macros today they start me over
and constantly like you're lifting today
so these need to be an explosive day so
after these gels have these bars and
it's just how much we're willing to
fight we've now got a team who's willing
to put that science in and i think if
you can if you can
make a fighter an athlete
they're going to go so much further than
a fight an athlete who can't be a
fighter you know like
like you love people i don't know if i
should really say because he's achieved
so much and as i'd fight big fights but
emilia khan was an ultimate athlete he
was so technical yeah but then his chin
wasn't a fighter and i'm not trying to
be disrespectful i'm just trying to like
explain what it means
we've all seen those kind of fighters
and you're completely right like you
know you
if it's not in you
you can only get to a certain level
whereas if the fight is in you and then
you can hone the athletic skills you can
go as far as you want really
yeah yeah because as long as you're
willing to push and work harder then why
not
do what i mean and with you like you are
generally at a bit of a disadvantage in
every fight at that weight class because
you're smaller a little bit of a mike
tyson style when you're in there you're
having a peek-a-boo and get around these
uh straight shots coming at you can't be
easy have you ever thought about
dropping down away um yeah we put me on
the dexa machine we seen
can make and what i can make safely now
here's here's the flip side of the coin
i could knock people out to a five foot
eight and i've got a nine inch reach
advantage of me
i just wasn't applying correctly and i
hadn't i hadn't smoothed it out to know
what i mean so sometimes
this is a good statistic i've generally
only lost to people who've been popped
for steroids
and saved bands wow so
i'm cool with that our name sami lost
two losses
one gay has been off now because
she's been pub for steroids and the
gayle before has just fought chebchenko
and arguably pinched the fight could
have got a draw could have gone either
way so when all you've known is being
small it's not that hard because you
kind of have to give yourself like a
little man's syndrome like well i've got
to enforce the fight and sometimes the
fights the people are that long
i have to just press press press press
press press press press whereas
this fight is the face fighting my whole
life where i've got one inch reach on
the opponent so
you're just going to see a totally
different fight it's going to be very
different
i know yeah in regards to you dropping
down away and obviously it's your career
you know yourself best but you know we
remember the way mcgregor was at
featherweight compared to what he is it
otherwise
and you think with your power if you did
drop it i don't know i'd have to drop
too much muscle really so that's the
yeah sorry i i've got digressed a little
bit there yeah it would be i'd have to
run the legs off myself and
the girls are still taller than me i
thought wait everyone's still five five
five six
but like post mma i would like to finish
in boxing i started amateur box and i'd
like to finish there with a few fights
but i'll probably drop to 120. i fight
at 125 the five pound difference isn't
too much because i'm i've got myself
down to just the water load that gets
three four pounds off me
the last three days and then i've made
weight whereas
if i've done that in boxing i just have
to have a bath or two to get the other
five pounds off so i'd probably do that
but ten pounds of big ask do you know
what i mean especially when you're
already cutting a lot obviously and
running and doing all your training it's
not like you can just do more cardio
you're already tired so you mentioned
boxing there that's fascinating because
i see you on the zone you obviously know
what you're talking about you like me
you're passionate about all fighting
yeah we're seeing some big fights being
made from mma fighters stepping in there
with boxers and all sorts so is there
anyone out there in boxing who you think
you know what i'd like i'd like a fight
with you i reckon i could have you yeah
there's a few
i watch
my weekends lads
like friday come home there's never any
sport on but satis like watch the
football or go the football come home
and watch the boxing and then
even if i'm out in time come home and
then the ufc's ufc is on so my weekends
just sport base them i don't i wouldn't
like to do like a crossover like go
there and come back like by the time i
have a box and it would be because i
want a career in boxing yeah
it seems like that's the mistake they
make isn't it where they're trying to go
away
you can't play you can't play boxing you
can't dip your toe yeah you it's like
you could never do that with mma either
so people are doing it for the wrong
reasons mine would be like legacy and
from when meatball was this big like my
dream was to to it was to go to an
olympics for boxing book my week
category wasn't ordered so that's why i
went to mma but um
he always i've got it in my mind
when katie taylor has a last fight i
know this is mad i want to be on that
card i just would like to share that
moment and just have my debut on that
card because it's years down the line
like
i'm television on mma
but you'd be naive not to think about
what's after mma don't know like what
what what's next for your future yeah
what a legend katie taylor isn't her
last fight against amanda serrano was
poor unbelievable i was i was sat with
jake paul's family it was tough i had
cyborg on me left um my ryan goss here
on my right
and i ended up having made it with one
of their
with one of the lads skye nicholson
didn't i wear the boxy yeah yeah yeah
she was like molly tell them kids to sit
down so
so i i've asked one of i've asked the
mom i said excuse me darling please may
you ask your kids to sit down they can't
see
and then the dad's not hated and he's
eat like the dad's record and he's gonna
who the do you think he's speaking
to my kids don't you ever touch my kids
what are you going on about oh i said
i'm not asking them behind me i said i'm
only asking what they've said he's
gone for me now bearded man it
was this do you know who this guy was no
i don't know who his name was um and i
wouldn't even give him the airtime
however
it got to a point where i didn't want to
disrespect i'm molly who loves her i
kick off live for it what a fault i've
got two kids they were like five and six
sat in front of me
the parents are just recording them
because it's for their vlog
and then i've got my cousin on watching
me cousin in the ring fight it was round
five so she was getting like filled in a
bit and then i was just thinking oh i
want to punch this man's head and then i
couldn't
and then flee more rounds kept going and
he's going
what was he saying ah your cousin's
going to get she's getting beat
and all this then shout out bar steals
for steve port no he's like the man yeah
he's just gone how you the are you
talking to and then cyborg stood up then
ryan garcia stood up and i was just
there and i was going to the lads
please don't ruin this moment i was like
you're obviously like mvp promotion so
you want amanda to win katie's my family
don't waste this don't ruin this don't
ruin this and then at the end they
honestly fought he won right right so
he's turning the camera around on my
face waiting for it and when casey when
casey won i just went i didn't even
i didn't even do anything and then after
the fight he just went i'm really sorry
about that i was just in the moment and
he went it's mad doesn't it it turns
absolute bastards fighting like when i
watch a fight and i watch my like
there's there's reactions of me watching
fights and i cringe at them there's
actually a reaction of me watching your
fight i'll probably send you where you
get the knockout and i'm going up and
i'm like
why do i have to behave like this it
turns me into the worst version of me
yeah well it might but you're excited
this mum was being a
yeah and he was being aggressive to me
and i thought
i'll clean i'll smoke you clean but then
of course could you imagine eddie hayne
looking at me i like i've closed me on
foot of course i have so i just paused
don't do it i had a tear rolling down me
out because i was like
did i like when the hulk was trying not
to change and he's like
i was like
oh i love you
like this guy has no idea how lucky he
is you know who i am now oh my god
he's probably like me i nearly got
chin by a woman in front of everyone
because the
um jake paul's like manager or person
who runs like mvp with him he was like
hi meatball you're the elbow girl and
all that like
like they all knew who it was so he was
just being a dick he was just
entitled and sometimes rich
do you know when you think of like
entitled when you speak about the white
privilege of a white american man like
mid-forties rachel that i was like oh
you're often you don't know
reality you you and it wasn't
like you were throwing your weight
around anyway you were asking politely
weren't you so yeah i just came round
went to sky that was your faulty
and she was laughing at her i
wouldn't care because that sky girl she
looks like an angel despite being an
unbelievable boxer if she'd have asked
they probably just would have been like
okay you know like because demeanor was
but yeah but i wasn't even black i was
dressed that girly my hair was down i
wasn't swearing i wasn't like giving me
a pint
i didn't have a vape in my mouth
i'm not in front of the kids i'm sorry
it's just like it's the biggest fight of
life well you're female you're at a
boxing event though you know like that
but you're where you're supposed to be
they they yeah the kids should be in bed
like you know yeah uh
god you're so easy to talk to molly
credit honestly a good interview
i've had two coffees
where the hell was i going with this the
fact that this guy confronted you it
made me wonder because obviously men
have a demeanor and they speak to women
in a certain way sometimes and obviously
along the years i would assume a man at
some point has made that mistake with
you of not realizing like this woman
could could eat me alive here uh has
that happened and if so what did you do
there's a famous there's a famous story
this
i've said it before buddy i was waking
on subway i was about
23. it was a night shift on some gale it
was like five in the morning so i'm like
still cutting sandwiches like this
trying to stay away
and some gears like stumbled in
and then this man's come on come over to
him put his arm around it and i was just
thinking that's a bit suspect so i went
lad what's her name he went over you the
busiest
i went now i said well like
he was a foreign man and his english
wasn't too great and i knew she was like
she sounded well so forth what what's
the connection there like how's that
happen so anyway me and him ended up
having amazing
and
he dragged the girl and tried to get the
gail out of the shot so me
me mate to me was running to the back
i've run outside to go and get him
and as i've run outside he's going to he
kicked me and i've laid back and just
chopped his leg but as this has happened
sorry before the fights kicked off he's
on the phone and ran back up so like a
few cars have bounced into the to this
road it this is romney street so this is
like central liverpool five o'clock in
the morning beds treating you know when
you come out of the nightclubs and
you're like whoa
and all these cars have come out and all
these lads in the cars
but where's the maidens run in the back
she's running with the busiest and i've
come out had to straighten with this lad
he's off
the busiest have come in locked the shop
trying to take a statement off the scale
turns out he had put date rape in here
drinking a nightclub and then watched
hey
come to subway
then
um he was trying to get here in the car
and on human trafficking so basically
i've i've plucked it and caught him and
then he got picked up from the busy and
then
he was a legal immigrant and he got
deported and sent back to wherever he
was from
so don't mess with the meatball not all
heroes were careful unbelievable
literally that should have been
everywhere by the way like well i so i
remember my bucket my coach not me
boxing coach ellis hanson it was a
saturday morning
and by the time i spoke to the business
on my statements i wasn't glassing but i
had to give a statement to what happened
he
he what he called
i had text him and he was like you need
me to come down is everything okay and i
was like it's just funny that like that
was way way way back then still to know
to me in her name but because i hadn't
even had my first ever main fight i
didn't i didn't even think to say
anything about it to be honest but it is
a funny story and and i sent him the
video so you could see like the camera
that would be like on the safe and the
tail just just glimpsed outside on them
on the glass and you could just see me
in this loudly i've got my apron
on a little hat like gloves what
you make you still be somebody didn't
slip and throw them coming back
and this lad this lad's not in pure
jean-claude van damme lately
he's throwing head kicks
yeah if someone's throwing head kicks he
knows something like you know it wasn't
one of those where it's just a random
guy so that yeah fair play at you i
watch a lot of crime stuff and the
amount of people who don't intervene
when they say something and that's often
how people like this girl become a
victim is because someone who could have
said something or intervene
because we naturally people just don't
want the hassle but fair play like
you've literally you basically saved her
life like how does that make you feel
knowing that you've had such an impact
on someone without even that's amazing
she was a real she was so pissed
out of red i was like you want me to put
you in the taxi home love and all that
and she was like now i just got off and
got on got a train back to like wales
somewhere i was just thinking you have
no clue what yeah no clue he's
just about to be like
sent off to romania or somewhere like
you've got no albania god
never seen again i don't think anything
into it but it's a funny story did she
never get back and touch nothing no
because
the business at all i can't believe that
like
that's what i think she was that
embarrassed and freaked out it looked it
weighed about me today with me like she
was safe i was tired and just
wanted to go to sleep and then i have to
go to train and so all in a day's work
for molly mccann ladies and gentlemen
all in a night shift on subway buns
unbelievable so this is just before your
mma career then so
so at this point from the research i've
done obviously you've grown up in
liverpool were you always feisty were
you always not scared of a tear-up did
you have a natural attitude for fighting
and martial arts or
um
since i was very young like five six
seven my uncle just added me on to bruce
lee and
jackie chan and um golden harvest faith
productions i think it was all that and
it was like
i always have a funny story when i was
like eighth i mean nanny had given me
five pounds for christmas
and i went can we go to i think it was
called borders then or some book shop i
don't think it's a boat anymore but it's
like waterstones
and i walked in and i got two books and
one was called scally and it was a
it's the book about the evertonian
away days and the other book was
in bruce lee's
striking philosophy on life and and his
life story and then i just remember like
me nana me mum like what the is up
with her like why is she
what's going on but i was always drawn
to it but it was too small
i had a really tough upbringing where i
was very shy
very angry and um
and when i was
11 i think i got i went into school one
day and got him
got boosted by some gays i went to
secondary school down south so when i
went in i just got busters all
the time and well for a few weeks and
then me well it was you
yeah i mean mum went right you see you
going to karate so i went to karate and
then
when i went in back to school the gayle
tries to do me and i just jumped on a
bus strangles in in the playground
properly and they could choke without
knowing it on him and then she never
came and no one ever came again so i was
like
yeah but i was still a bit of a
and quite quiet but the more sport that
i've done the more confidence it gave me
to be who i am and and then i started
coaching within sport because when i was
16 17 because i'd done a few years
um the boxing gyms would be like we'll
teach the kids when they come in and
then that kind of just i just sport and
teaching and coaching i just like ran
alongside each other even till now
like i'm one of the coaches on the
english mma association
like a coach in that on that weapons
down gloves up initiative with tony
bellew and david hughes and billy moore
and then we just help the kids in the
gym whenever we can as well i definitely
want to talk about that because i have
had billy my
podcast what a story he has jesus uh and
tony i'm good mates with uh love those
guys um but going back to your um
your inner anger we see that come out in
its passion
and and as fans
i think that's why we love you and we've
gravitated towards you so much is
because you let it all out and
in boxing there's nothing worse than a
press conference or a weigh-in or
anything where i'm looking at two
fighters seeing everything that i can
predict beforehand and not being the
real them and you do let that out but th
this fire inside you this anger and what
was sort of horned in you as a kid
where does that what is the cause of
that do you think what is the reason
a lot of them
of trauma
mm-hmm a lot of abandonment a lot of
family and loved ones like me biological
dad everyone just get muffins just being
like well why aren't i enough like why
am i so
why haven't i got a stable home why
haven't i got
your traditional family what everyone
else has got
and um i think my mum just raised me to
just be like
the whales i used you for her
to go out and get what you once like
she said to me once you're i know you'll
always be all right because you cut from
my cloth you're made of what i'm made of
and i just thought i was i missed school
like i missed quite a lot of stuff
growing up so many developments was a
little bit behind so the way in which i
had to make up for it was applying
myself
so
hard work beats talent when talent
doesn't work hard the oldest cliche in
the booth but even when you come down to
my fights
technically
and
somatotype wise people i i've got to
upper hand on me because of the length
so the shots and shot selection can be
more varied than what mine is
but i'm i'm willing to wait harder than
than that person and i remember being a
kid walking to boxing gyms now walking
through this with jim's know this this
is no no gears no gears no gears it was
traditional mark it was karate
kickboxing and thai boxing which
welcomed me
and i think it was good that i laid the
traditional values of karate
and then like the spiritual values of
like
thai boxing like a thai taught me to
play thai boxing
and when you learn that you have a
different respect for
the sport do you know what i mean it's
not like that's just have a scrap
it's like there's that you're going into
the ring you're feeling the good energy
and you're kicking the good energy out
you meditate and you
it's just got so much to do with it and
then by the time i met boxing i got to
throw it all together
and then
i think just
in the mma always in every fight i'm map
and something goes wrong someone dies
someone's diagnosed as the dying the
father break up with me girlfriend like
or an ex or something like big and
life happens or i've lost the fight so
i've lost two fights and then got to
come back and i just think
how'd you come back you just it's this
this is all it is so
i know sometimes people will be the same
with you but i would they'd be like how
is he going again like how
animated we are or how much we care
about our stuff but like that's because
we've had to wait for everything and
we're just expressing ourselves so
because people know how much you give to
this
they do you are right people just get
involved and i'm always the underdog i i
think i'm always the underdog but it's
funny the last two fights before the
fight it's being my
biggest test to molly's career this this
the tenant leads non-intrigued two fight
win streaks blah blah blah i've gone and
smashed them to bits and then it's like
oh well that only comes it's just like
well i'm never going to win am i
oh
like you've never seen a finish like
that off a woman in in combat sports
really
like
maybe there's like there's like one
female in boxing they called like the
female mike tyson she comes in sleep
stuff that white woman with blonde hair
and she's just like oh it's like they're
the only times i've seen people like out
out for 15 20 minutes i love the fact
that you let all that out though like
when you talk about that trauma and like
me i've been a stranger for my own dad
for much of my life and i get i get what
you mean is like
it just builds and builds and years and
years of setbacks and issues and that's
why i i feel like that's like when we
see you on that stage and when you see
you in the cage that's your moment to
just
let it all out
yeah
and i feel like
yeah i just feel like him without like
regurgitating conor mcgregor when you
walk to that cage the shackles are off
like
it's the scariest it's literally giving
me goosebumps the scariest moment of my
life
is that moment
but it's the funniest i've ever felt and
many fighters will say because it's how
we feel but
you go into like your truest form of
life no one can with you in that
moment you know to me like i know how
hard i train i know how hard i am on
myself what i want i probably make fight
comes 50 million times harder for myself
because
the same like justin gates
i feel like i have to take myself to
somewhere where someone else can't can't
come and touch me and then when i'm in
that cage the fight's never as hard and
it's like you can go to
the last fight i had one shoulder um
the the time before that in ufc london i
had one eye in las vegas in september i
had a broken knuckle a
on these moments
it's just one of them if you're not
willing to give up on your dream
then you're going to go out and you're
going to give it and you can it's just a
release after when you're like i've just
done what i was made to do all of the
human problems that we have on
a day-to-day basis none of that matters
when you're in that cage because you're
you're going to some sort of like
caveman like you you know like it's
it's this is
humility like primal instinct absolutely
on what we were just talking about
before about all these setbacks
i really hope as a fan if anything
happens from here on out you start
facing it in a different way because in
my head it's like you've proved who you
are now
to yourself to everyone and if if you do
lose a fight or whatever it doesn't need
to be that massive crisis that it was
before i think you've now you're
established now you know yeah well i
feel like the
the level of competition and the level
of athletes is like elite level whale
classroom is
one two three percent stuff
that makes the difference to know to me
and so i can take that on the chin
the hardest part of the losses where
you knew they was on the juice or
they've just come off a suspension and
the way in which i've lost the face is
down to strength
that's the hard part to take but
i feel like there's been a lot of growth
like what you're saying
and in the last
loss
away to spain i just got away and i just
trained every day and just trained
through the pain but still lean to enjoy
me not taking us as rough men
but
i don't know try saying that to any
athlete
i mean i'm i'm saying this but then to
be fair you see some athletes and you go
he has he taken that hard enough you
know what i mean like with anthony
joshua there's been times he's lost and
i've been like you should be more bitter
you should be more so it is a balance
and and no one can really tell a fighter
how to take a loss i guess moving on to
uh the weapons down the weapons gloves
up thing like obviously everton uh in
liverpool football teams uh
they've they've got so many young kids
in this area
who and we say all the time like
stabbing shootings all of this thing and
and i guess this is what you guys are
trying to tackle is to get kids to be a
bit more like you guys there was bits
going on in the mma community and i just
left them to that because these were
people who had been stabbed before
like darren's being stopped don't have
to leave liverpool and go to brazil get
his head down come back
and fight again but
in the the boxing whales are seeing tony
bellew was doing bits with this and
obviously through the evident connection
and i met with him well i actually met
with billy moore first yeah he had a
real life and then i met david hughes
who's like the
he owns the the charity nexus that runs
the initiative i didn't really have too
much to do with it at all and then
there was a stabbing last christmas with
ava white i can't remember
young from
11 or 12 bloody hell there was a moment
where i remember being a child well
child 16 17 and three stones was killed
oh god yes
you remember these moments where these
mad things happened
he was an inevitable fan wasn't he from
uh yeah and he got hit from a ricocheted
bully from a arrival gang
he wasn't in the gang he's just playing
football in the park and yeah the guy
who shot that shot and hit the tree and
then ace hit him and he's bled out and
had a heart attack
i just couldn't believe that had
happened like she'd gone to watch the
christmas lights be late and i remember
saying to me gay girlfriend
like
it should blow me away like it's
completely
it's done me in and i just thought more
needs to be done for these kids more
needs to be done and
i just messaged dave was like i need to
be more involved so we sat down he was
like okay i'd like you to be a sponsored
athlete so
we put our name on the show to that kind
of thing and i was like i came in like
my ipad and all of the notes and i was
like no no this is what i want i was
like i want to be the thread that runs
between the kids and use on the board
and i want to
use my platform to bring eyes to bring
sponsorship to bring whatever we can and
to come and teach the kids so basically
that's what my role kind of is
david calls it like a community liaison
officer
um so i'll help coach the kids i'll come
in on days speak to them and it works
because
i'm from north korea i've grew up round
over
i've chose not to go down a pathway i've
seen my parents be a certain way i've
got to the pinnacle of a sport still
loose they'll get up still go again and
i think it just shows the kids that you
i don't really speak with like a very
high um vocabulary you know like
i still speak just like what the kids
would talk like and what people speak
like where i'm from
and um i just think that's relatable and
it's just seeing it's been different
since i've been a david hughes has
completely overtook it and he's like
running it himself now and it's a lot
more of a personal touching a jazzy
dickens the little boxer he's getting
involved um and it's just mad to think
that we're just a group of evertonians
and it hasn't worked out to be like
right as ever fans let's do this this
this and this
but it's turned out to be like the
people's club and the people of the
people's club are doing stuff for the
people and i think it's amazing because
there's a lot of these kids out here you
know they want to be hard lads they want
to carry what they want to carry and do
what they want to do but once you get in
that ring you realize who you really are
you know what i mean and you realize
you're not that hard and actually you're
just a scared little kid worried that
you're going to be found out for what
you really are which is a skinny or
something you can't fight most of the
time but once they get in there it puts
that into them like it actually does
toughen them up it does teach them
discipline and all the things that they
need and
it's a it's a shame that we don't have
more
focus on sport in this country because
as we've seen in america with the nfl
and the mba they get so many of these
young men out of poverty and out of
these situations and women obviously and
and not going down the wrong roads and i
think that there's just such a lack of
that
in
yes
i feel like there'd be loads of
initiatives and charity bills like the
same like i remember i was like to and
from london a lot a couple of years ago
and there's the fight for peace there's
a massive hope center in new room and
that gets kids off the street helps them
with feeds them helps them with the
school away and it's a physical outlet
for them to do jiu-jitsu mma boxing thai
box and then i feel like little bits
popping up but the coverage took its
toll on
on a lot of sponsorship this starting
over and i think it's just going to take
a little bit of time for it to come
again but
i don't know the premise of weapons down
is is not just to get not just to tackle
like
kids and gangs it it's open to anyone
who wants a life for themselves who's
not making the best of the situation so
they just start in
a gym
creating like good bonds with an
authoritative figure in a coach like
making better social skills get more
self-esteem creating a boutique and then
they go into the classroom then they get
the cc card and then they go on site and
then they learn and then they have a
full-time job at the end of it where son
the aftercare sometimes is just like you
know like if you was on the dole like
come and get you your card and then it's
up to the kid to go and look for the job
when they're not ready for the interview
process and all that where does this is
this is a package put together where you
you turn up your show up you get the
outcome you get to go and change your
life
and you build self-esteem as well
there's nothing there's nothing that
builds self-esteem about collecting your
dole from experience like it's uh it's
pretty miserable you know whereas you
like you say there's people to be held
accountable to there's people who care
there's actually someone who you're
answering to so yeah i think it's
fantastic that you guys do this i want
to go back to the sort of beginning of
your ufc career because
it couldn't have started very much
harder for you um you got in there
did you miss wait am i right and
thinking that you're right yeah so
so i fought like february 22
24th
25th
and then like mid-march i'd gone to a
cage while he was in london and graham
just stopped me down he went you're not
getting on ufc liverpool in may
we'll fight in september he he was like
they've just said you get 20 and 20 who
whoever was sponsoring cage bodies at
the time said they're going to give you
this money it's like four times what
you'd ever get for the ufc just do that
to make sound so just out there live in
my life fat jolly on the a all over and
then i get a phone call and then it's
like oh you're in the ufc so i was like
oh my god
so i had five six weeks to lose about 35
pounds wow and i win i win in any kind
of shape like i was
well you see an old molly was just
skinny faster than me
so i i'm on fight we i had to caught
five kilo the night before jesus so i
think i cut ten and a half
ten and a half pounds i needed to cut
eleven
and it was just like empowering remember
coach went
let's shave you here so i
i had an hour left to make way to let
shave your head i went how much am i
gonna lose
in money and he said two thousand pounds
i said no i'm not shaving behave
to pay two grand out of my pace so i
literally sat in the sauna till the time
like kept fainting and getting picked
back or thinking
i named
and went in
and it was
i'm not saying oconee and khabib that's
the level that me and jillian would have
but that's the styles that the fight was
so we should go to the floor julian was
always winning the fight and if it was
stood up i would have won the fight
and
it was the best thing and worst thing
that ever happened to me but because of
that moment
what can you do in your in your biggest
fall and you you your biggest defeat and
your biggest
adversity in life do you like point the
finger and say it was everyone else just
followed you looking teary and go what
can i do better so that's what happened
there took accountability from my own
flaws me coaching stuff took
accountability for well actually maybe
we could have done this mate maybe
they're starting over and i brought paul
reed on board as my nutritionist and i
bought carl evans on board as me
strength and conditioning coaching i
think with every fight from then you've
seen an engine you've seen big double
leg dumps you've seen constant
constant still remain
and
sometimes we'll have to have that
massive
oh moment there to to wake up and
change who we are and for you that was
obviously um
going to sleep in the cage and waking up
and obviously
thinking but can can you sort of
take me back to that moment of
you're fighting
you know she's choking you out and then
you wake up just remember what that was
like i remember she was on me back and i
knew for like she's in the air
and
i just thought just go with it like
if there's a chance
oh for those who haven't seen it you
haven't tapped you didn't touch no
no i was barely done she had a short
joke so a real naked choke you can like
attack the hands but a short choke
there's nothing you can't it's just it's
kittens and it was a proper heavy
portable
moments i just remember like
vision coming in me sound coming in
and
i remember coming round i'm not sure if
you've seen the documentary bt sport
don't know if me called me ball molly
but you just see me go over to like i'm
like i don't know what happened but it
didn't tap i didn't tap
and you go no no and i repeated to say
it about 12 times i didn't tap it didn't
top happen didn't happen i just prided
myself on the fact that i might be a
mouth and
i might be a lot of things but
i i was willing to
i wouldn't say dying there but like i
was willing to be to be put out to show
like that's how much i want to win
because people have tapped for well
people tap for less
yeah we've seen people tap like as soon
as anything's near their neck sometimes
yeah like like you could say the conor
mcgregor one on the jaw like even like
poorie when he was against khabib or he
tapped and i just think it's just
because they know that they're not
getting out of it so i understand
i'm not calling them
a little or anything i understand
i was just what i'm trying to say is we
i knew i was inexperienced i went out on
my shield don't mean don't think you're
going to fight weeks i'm going to
knock it out and then when it
gets tough given and and that's what i
tried to do and that's what i try and do
in every fight to be honest because
in every fight there's a moment of
obviously i face there's there's a
turning point in every single fight
um in the fight in september to go
knocked with a head clash
yeah you were dominating early yeah yeah
yeah and then and then
yeah it did that swayed that round but i
was it and then in the last
fight i feel like it was the last well
the last round the moment of obviously
was there am i tired am i just going to
settle and maybe just get just just
edged the win or am i going to step
forward and take what's mine and then
that's what i chose to do
obviously at that point you're it's do a
die in and they told you like you you
need to pull a win out here because we
can't have back-to-back defeats when
you've only just got here
what was it like knowing
okay my dream is really hanging in the
balance and how did you respond to that
income and then actually on the fight
then my ptsd my anxiety was like
me and paddy speak very very vaguely
about
like depression and suicidal thoughts
but i can't tell you that the
every single day
it felt like my dad had died again told
me i was just like
i couldn't get this i just could not
shake this feeling and
like the week of the fight me manager's
like
oh not the week of the fight it was the
whole camp
if molly gets finished
it's done
after that last fight mcmahon nods wades
to graham was like molly's jiu jitsu
shite she fixes it or she's gone like if
she gets finished by submission that's
it she's done like she's just not ufc
caliber
so then i just made the new mission to
be like fine i'll show you that
i can submit someone and then i i've
really tried my best i like i had this
game in an arm armbar invaded again and
it robbed me it would have rubbed me off
my glory i think with the eye so i'm
glad that
the fight carried on and i got to to
show people i'm not like we're talking
about these moments of obviously i've
won the first round second round's close
but i've edged it and then we're coming
to the last round i'm like put your
stamp on it now face 50 seconds
pop orbitals blown and you know if you
lose
that's it you're done and it's just like
how does how does a broken orbital feel
like obviously painful but like what is
that like for you especially getting
repeatedly punched in that
i just felt it was there inside so it
wasn't like my cheek it was like profit
in here
and so i'll explain it to you it's this
eye so you'll see this eyes a bit
smaller than this one
okay okay so the the tear duct on the
top i've got a massive scar but you
can't see it will split all the way up
there
the bone that broke my sinus attached to
so when
it was fixed the next day they had to
take the sinus off reattach the sinus
they had to open me up there and so all
inside my eye and then they have to fix
this now if they didn't align the eyelid
properly i'd got stencils of the eye and
like
it wouldn't it wouldn't fit or
it just it's a lot of like
agreement to remain but we talk about
like how does it feel did you see me
running around that cage after that it's
like i wasn't asked i was like
wow
honestly
you are tough as nails yeah like yeah
like well i took some hardens in that
cage like when i thought i'll tell you
something across the knees to the face
the kicks just i'll still keep coming
from sledgehammer at me i'll take it but
i just remember thinking
wow then we went to the whole hospital
and he's on a ct on a mri and they're
like yeah you're all right you have to
come back tomorrow when the swelling's
like got to its most and then we can
stitch it up so i've gone sad
so then i've got a bottle of vodka out
of me bag and i'm like on the great
deuce we're all drinking we're all
buzzing honey and then when we're at the
hotel having a bevy we're waiting to
watch like darren fight on the tv i'm
i'm there with all my gym
everyone
all my family
and then we got a phone call
uh sorry it's not okay she's got a um
what was it the ct has come back sorry
she's got a broken orbital bone so i'm
flying around with like a i put
like a plaster on my eye to stop it it
was just spitting on everyone oh
and then
it was like two in the morning lads and
like
the doctor the ufc doctors come over we
still drink and they go
what is she doing she's got surgery and
seven hours get her to bed so the mates
have got got a pizza and they're like
cokes and me to me room because once
i've had a nail that's it i'm like gone
and then i remember waking up in the
morning
and they took me the
the hospital and i was just pissed at me
i'd still like it was saint patrick's
day and i was like yes and i was just
looking at instagram and i just took
over like instead for a bit and then
i lay there i mean mums walked in
our name the anesthesiologist has come
in and got a name
have you been drinking ale i went yeah i
had a few last night and he was like how
much i went like just a quarter bottle
of vodka and she went you liar
tell them the truth i went like a little
bottle of vodka
so proper skull say i took my own i have
bottles of vodka and bottles of gin
stashed in the couches in the hilton so
that all me mates and i could just fill
their own bevy up and then go and get
like a coke from the bar because
like no one's balling you know what i
mean yeah london's expensive yeah this
was early days as well one day it's just
early days yeah
paddy's still do that now
it was hard for a long time after two
weeks after the operation i had the
check hoping they went you're like
wolverine why you went because you fixed
like you fixed already i was like no way
two weeks after i send a picture to gray
and boiling of me i signed off five days
later i flew to santorini for a wedding
i'm as i'm on saturday the night before
the wedding before my best friends i was
a bridesmaid
get a phone call
um yeah you're fighting in eight weeks i
was like whoa
let me like what i named
i didn't i didn't get touched to the
head for we done six weeks no head
contact was a fourth no matter what a
break takes after six six weeks to heal
and then i went into that next fight
against aryan lipsky i was like 4-1
underdog
it everywhere
and then the mental side still didn't go
anywhere down to me and it was still
rough and then i had ufc boston
and beat that diamond lisa
like three or four in a row right yeah
and then and then i went on a two-fight
skid but i'll tell you this why
because there was no crowd i'm just
telling you i couldn't do it i couldn't
do it without the crowd and then you
look at me last two performances with a
crowd
it's just it's night and days
yeah that's what i need i mean
maybe i'm gonna have to learn to not
deal with it like to deal with not
having it but i feel like
when you're talking to me about
releasing all of that
that inner and just getting through
it that's the
it's in that moment that i need
the fans everyone in me fights even on
cage bodies that had moments of
adversity the second i cried go they
know i fight for them so it just gives
me an extra life flood i'm like
you uh
you are a people's champion like that's
a that's a word that's thrown around
that is you like there's not even in
question at this point um you obviously
had the two fight losses but then you
came back
and you put on an unbelievable
performance fight of the night i
remember just being like
wow like that was i think for me
personally that was when i really had
that moment and connected with you and i
one of the specific memories was when
you got the phone call after the fight
and you were crying
and it was one of those where as fans we
say like we're watching your life change
you know and we're connecting and
because we got to see that it meant a
lot
however
it could make me cry that moment because
life had being tough man
and
when i was in the cage
i knew
because i had like a toenails yell and
my knuckle was and i knew my life
like was on that moment
a my basement was like how did
you feel i was like i just wanted
i was just
i was so relieved yeah and
the casuals can always troll me
and say what they want but people who
know mma
you watch that and you just imagine the
did
that look i lost that fight i was gone
from the ufc i won the fight in that in
that nature and i was right back in it
and
imagine having to fight someone with a
tenant treats advantage on yeah
it was just so hard and i just i was
just so buzzed and when i got
that money i just thought i'm getting a
new fake on i know i'm gonna get a new
car of course yeah and then i thought
in in in all honesty you get fifty
thousand dollars america takes 30
percent you then lose
six seven percent in the exchange rate
you then have to give you team 10
percent your management 10
and then pay english tax so you're not
getting 50 but you're still getting a
lot and that's what then allows my life
to change
to then create for the next camp and
then obviously i've come into london
i've won that i managed to get a six
figure deal with barstool after
hey shout out
and now i feel like i've got
i'm comf i'm comfortable
where i'm not like scared about the next
chair but i'm not comfortable in terms
of where i am in my career and where
they need to be so there's always like a
fine balance of not getting carried away
you know what i mean and that last
performance obviously that was the
crowning moment of your career where
it's a star was born you know i compared
it to mas vidal it really did remind me
of that knockout mazda i had where
everyone was like oh this guy is
the real deal and the tail one or the
one the the ascerine one specifically i
felt like the fight where you got your
fight of the night bonus was it made us
pay attention more
it solidified your name and then the
knockout was like and she's a star and
like boom it happened that quickly um
like for uk mma you're basically a
trailblazer you're literally
you're becoming the best thing of female
mma in the uk like you're you're going
to be that person that people look at
and go she was the first like to do it
in the and have a longevity there and
actually yeah ups and downs of course
but more ups and and the ups are amazing
you know so like the highs are highs and
the lows are lows and i know there's
there's amateurs coming through and
little chanel dyer who fights for
england and there's pros coming through
in in dakota a from manchester top team
and i know i know these two gays will
make the ufc one day and nobody will and
i just want to make sure the bar that i
i set is raised higher than it's gonna
make them do better than what i've done
still during me like my legacy is my
legacy and and no one will ever be able
to like to touch that or come near it
because no one's out to go through what
i've been through so i remain whereas
these other gays are coming through
it's been a bit easier in some ways and
it may have been a bit harder in other
ways but dude well that's natural isn't
it it's not it's you know it's not your
fault
the this is michael um bisping made
the road for daryn till easier like and
you're doing the same for these women
because now they see how people react to
you they'll want more and uh and i guess
the bisping comparison is accurate as
well because
no one has quite had the love that
bisping got yet i think paddy is on his
way and darren had had had flashes of it
but obviously he's had a setbacks but
but with you i feel like you're doing a
similar thing where people win or lose
you've got them in the palm of your hand
and that's powerful i feel like if
people really know me they know that i'm
a good person and you know what to do
for me community for me city
what to do for anyone who i know i'll
i'll try me best because
we're there to pay it forward to know
what i mean and i just would never want
someone to feel how i've had to feel
growing up and that's the top and bottom
of it
but like you will have other people who
are loved for their mouths you know like
paddy can sell the stadium
lightweight because he's that
controversial
you know what i mean it but sometimes
even if i lose
more people come in aids to me where
sometimes you can get people when they
lose it goes quiet i think sergio
martinez said the famous thing
when he lost to
miguel cotto like when he won his whale
tightly he had like 180 missed calls and
the next day when he lost to carter we
had eight and he was all off his mum i
don't know what i mean i think it
depends on what you sell yourself as
like conor mcgregor sold himself as the
greatest thing ever so when he loses it
it's tough to to to maintain that
whereas for bisping for you
it's about what you're willing to give
to the fans and that that hit that we
feel that it really does make a
difference and i wondered if you were
getting a little bit of that jealousy
yet if you were getting a bit of that in
the city yet i can handle this i can
handle people who don't like me because
i'm an evertonian i can handle people
not being into women and fighting
because they're old school and they
don't
they their values are that not that
women should be at home in the kitchen
you just don't like women getting hit
and and i know it's a sport but i can
empathize with the full process of
getting i have to take on the chin that
some people won't like me because i'm
gay top and bottom of it because
i still don't drink in the same bruises
i still go and
i'll get i'll get the bus i'll get an
uber like i'm just walking through town
every day
um
i'm still me i'm not flash i like i
literally go and sit on all the irish
pubs and just watch the match and i aim
do you know what i'd love i'd love you
to have the tony bellew stadium moment
oh listen did you see before crystal
palace so
did you see when we won aim and didn't
get relegated i was on the i was
on the pitch i was the davis
but before the match yeah someone put me
on my shoulders and i had flares i was
like this and everyone was going
meatball meatball
and i
someone recorded it and sent me and then
i put it on me instant afford i love
this club and they love me like i don't
love the board i don't love the
toxic toxicness of the club but i feel
like that
auntie gordon said the best the fun like
everton are the fans like like true like
we change that we change that for
that club
you were getting relegated if it wasn't
for the fans like
you guys basically saved that club
because you were going down 100
and but it took
it took the club and it took the fans to
split to come back together
to me and just create and even at that
that last game we went watch you know
down at half time i'm at the table with
david hughes and i was going lad i just
started drinking and i was like nailing
the pines going for party's gonna
absolutely rub it in my face
and then when i came i went if we win
i'll i'll shave my eyes i'll do
a skinner listen when that fade girl
went and they was like get their
clippers out
you mentioned before about women in
fighting and how some people have that
old school mentality and i've heard this
from you know i've old boxing coaches
and and things like that you know like
it's around but but it's changing 100
and people like katie and like yourself
or helping the shift and the fact that
the matter is is you've got more fight
in you
than
99.99 of male fighters like that you've
you're brave you're right there's no
doubt in that
don't know yeah just
and just the skulls say that's all like
people go what is this i'm just a
sculpture but what's that been like not
every scout says like that like there's
a lot of i've watched scouse fighters
who are very defensive and and haven't
got that gung-ho ball to the world so
what has it been like for you as a woman
in a male-dominated environment
what kind of experiences have you had
where because i'm sure there must have
been times where people have been a few
tough times but don't get me wrong this
city shows nothing but love to know when
i lost the jillion
i literally left and went to chinatown
and i've walked in to a chinese and as
i've walked in everyone's gone
because obviously everyone would be into
the fight and i'd had a few stitches and
i was like that and i sat down and this
man came and put a hundred pounds let me
tell you we went you're not buying your
own food tonight here congratulations
for what you've done
and i was just like
what i was like i couldn't even eat i
was like just give me a pinky and i'm
like i can't even eat it anyway but
this like
i run through this city i'll ride the
bike to the gym and you just say
the city will be on me and i
love this city and i fight like it's
literally i say it all the time but
where is it it's there my city my people
my heart and
i don't know some people are cringing
i'm like look at when one of
the proudest things of your
your makeup is to be where you're from
and to represent skulls culture to try
to represent that's like for the best
part of me sometimes the worst part i've
represented for i like i'm only human
and i really try i want to talk to you
about your uh partnering crime paddy um
that moment of you obviously on the on
the cage together celebrating together
it was as iconic uh as as we've seen in
the ufc it really did warm the heart um
what were your first impressions of when
you first met paddy what was he like i
walked in
and
i think the first time i spoke to him i
think we just sparred
and he just started to skin it i've seen
that video where he's got his skin as
he's got braces and he goes
they call me a positive body and he's
just chills like that that's what he was
like glad he was just like
whatever yeah
and as he's grown into his manhood and
he's filled out
he's really smart he's really
intelligent and
sometimes you think oh you joke
and why have you said that
there was there was a big time when we
we'd come in the gym and go oh what's he
doing again you know what i mean
and then there's something on twitter
probably
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying and
then there's a lot of times where we sit
there and go
what have you done
like wow do you know what i mean like
there's a lot of what you've done
he was just always cool and me and him
are just total opposite butler
i'm a red he's a blue i'm a girl he's a
boy he's jiu-jitsu i'm straight and
beast
but we're so proud of where we're from
we're so proud of what we embody and
when we go in there we both fight the
same way yeah
we do when we don't if you know what i
mean our styles
but our like
your bravery is on a par with each other
you both throw everything out there and
it's kill or be killed and to us you're
like brother and sister if i was to say
to you who was the real paddy like cause
we see the showman now
i call him patrick i never call him
possible right
um
he
is gentle
he's funny he's kid and pretty surprised
like when he was in san diego he's like
lord of his fiance can i have a whole
god
off
like he's just so nice and then yeah
and then in the same breath sometimes
he's moody a little miserable bastard if
he's weighing heavy and his weight's not
come down as fast as he's supposed to
um he only needs to be told once and
then he can do it
other than keep his chin down
you can't do that
um did you say yeah
telling him like you need to put your
wallet under your chin
uh yeah you we used to say put a
50-pound message yeah obviously paddy
right now he is taking off as one of the
most talked about
fighters
in the ufc in the world even have you
felt like there's been changes because
it's only natural as a young man
no
no um i know what you're going to say
and now
he reached stardom at the age of 21 22.
he lost the plot for a good two or three
years
he lost everything and he's built
himself back so
it's a good thing he got to laying in
front of like 50 000 instagram followers
as opposed to the world now okay um
he knows what he wants he's getting
married next year
his team all of us are his family
and we keep it tight-knit
and um
i feel like the more notoriety we've
both got
the the tighter the circle becomes
that's a smart way to play it from
experience
like don't get me wrong there was a
point where we both i never reached his
notoriety the first time rounds when he
did but i've still noticed like where my
life's changed
say from september to
last september to like december just
before the last fight camp like my life
changed and i've seen who was in my life
at the parties and who
just would go out with me and who was
there in the fight camp and who knows if
they had a bad
some friends of mine go we love about
you and go in the game so i'll just see
you when you know to come like i have
good people who know how to do that too
we we're quite lucky um
i've had to do a lot of growing
and especially after that last fight i
understand and life has changed
like you're changing as well for the
better you're trying to become more
serious so the people who want about
your positive growth need to go i guess
yeah and i suppose i've made mistakes
still
thinking something's acceptable and it's
not all like
putting me things or
never really being rude but like i have
to open my open my eyes to see my
situation and
it's not actually all just about me all
the time because life is so overwhelming
with media and with everything and you
can't walk down the street which is
people constantly like i was on facetime
to me godson and my best friend
yesterday a seven minute walk i must
talk about six pictures do you know me
and i was just like i'm literally
headphones and sunglasses on and just
walking down that's like
i'd say you don't
you're now public property so that's
what i've had to get my head around and
it's hard
giving the whales everything and then
coming home and not giving me part or
something or giving me mum something or
me friends but the closest people know
this has just got a shelf life and once
it's done i can be
molly and i don't have to be meatball
again
i mean very much sure do you
this fame thing it's a weird one because
it can be draining as you've just
rightly explained but then it can also
be fun and and it's it's about like not
letting it control you almost you have
to control it i guess so that's that's
what i've i've come to teams with
by not dancing with the devil
um
and having people around you to keep you
honest um
like me gay friends absolutely
kept me in check and written me a new
like recently because because of
my behavior oh really what kind of
behavior do you think that needed
checking i'm
done in all the time all the
time i haven't got the energy and it's
just like well your life's going to be
like that so you can't just keep being
rude or short or just disrespectful joe
to me like it's not here fault so why am
i taking it out you take it out on your
closest person to you of course you know
what i mean
and i have to grow and i have to lean
and understand and compromise
and she pushes me to be the best me that
i could be i couldn't have done that
last fight without it
and it's just it's just the last fight
camp without society just cause me
injury and
just she just helped me through so it's
just getting uh making sure everything's
okay
and not just like
say i've got loads of fires i've got to
keep them all stoked the same i'm not
just like putting on yeah
and prioritizing what's important as
well and try i guess trying to calm calm
yourself down when you are run down and
realize actually why am i run down and
whose fault is that and why is that yeah
i've got adhd so my i'm like this i can
tell ya
sometimes last like it's
it's i've had so much personal growth
recently on understanding myself because
of it don't mean she's like well look at
this this this and this maybe you need
to address this and i was like
so that's why i can't
process that and that's why this is
overwhelming for me and
shows the never ending cycle of
growth this this thing called life isn't
it how long
do you mind me asking how long have you
been with your girlfriend
um about nine months eight months eight
nine months sounds like she's made a
very big impact on you in that time
she's very wise
she's the total opposite opposite of me
she's from the area or did you meet him
from sheffield
i went to another game and assassinate
and she was just sat next to me she
waited
two weeks for the club yeah wow
obviously i read up on you in real and i
did a bit of like
understanding
what it's like for someone coming out as
i'm i'm reading about your life and it
it's not something i've had to do so
obviously this is sort of i'm finding it
quite fascinating that the pressure that
you described
uh that you can't all the fears that
someone would go through
um can you sort of explain a bit about
how you came to that point of i'm ready
now versus the original feelings of oh
god it's you're never ready it's like
probably fine i'll be pregnant i imagine
you're not expecting it to know what i
mean like no one
no one i don't think is truly ready um
just because of the language and the
vocabulary and the the attitude towards
gay people and
it's just it's always been hard
so
it was only being in and around the gym
that made me feel safe
that's all it is like
i've done enough there's enough on that
to know that being there's like
it's obviously gay pride month and all
of that and there's literally like a
um
as i could guess that's a edited in the
metro today about me coming out slowly
there's loads where
family friends just people are educating
themselves more on how they can make
people feel and i just think me coming
out my friends and family i'm were
mortified that they ever felt i couldn't
because of maybe how they had been
so when people take accountability and
i'm not saying they were homophobic
jonah mean but just like
just little words or jokes like in the
90s people could get away with being
homophobic and racist and jokes because
he wasn't getting called on it and then
people woke and got
got fresh to that you know i remember
like it doesn't even matter about being
gay like you'd get one for being a
geordie being working class being a
skull set everyone as they think that
they've got to overcome in the life do
you know what i mean and
kelly holmes is literally doing it
nowadays and she sees that she's riding
that big big wave and it's also really
like everyone knew but for us
and then people are shocked why we have
this whole i'm really scared to come up
well the world has made us that
way so of course all of your actions
yeah yeah exactly and i've seen that you
wrote a children's book on uh that thing
so uh credit do you i think it's great
that you are trying to sort of um tell
your story to kids in in a way they can
digest it as well
thanks lord appreciate it man and also
but just just while we're on that topic
of your love life i just wondered
getting a little bit famous right in
that in that what did that make things
interesting for you before you found
your part now were you like wow i'm
getting attention from this girl and
that girl and i've never been like
openly gay and single i don't really
think but what i did realize is like i'm
not someone i'm not like a womanizer
them objectified women like like that's
not that's not me and i'm still really
shy about my relationship and
putting it on social media and things
still life really freaked me out
to be honest
why does it freak you out
just because everyone's got
something to say
and i'm not bothered but like when
you're still coming to teams with like
your
every time you have to talk about
your coming out story you you're going
through the process again right if
you've ever had a breakup or a
or a member of your family's passed away
and you speak about it sometimes it like
it comes but like
unfortunately like i chose to try and
change
people's lives by or help people by
talking about my story so that's my
i have to deal with
i feel you on that i've talked about
certain traumatic things that have
happened to me before and it's sort of
there's a point where you go right i
know i'm doing good by saying this but
unfortunately i'm becoming that guy who
then whenever i'm in an interview this
traumatic is going to be brought up
and i'm like ah so yeah i'm sorry for
like if i've pride or anything
no i appreciate you sharing and uh and i
and i get especially why if in a
relationship that's a nine-month uh
relationship why you'd also be
protecting your your other half as well
and not
put pushing it
to all the fight shows
like anywhere i go she's there she came
to america with me and came and done all
the bar steal stuff and that like i
don't know it's just the less people
know about the business
the easier your business is
um one one last question on the paddy
thing as well uh we had logan paul on my
podcast in the last week and he called
out paddy and said that uh he wants to
fight
and uh
in it you know it's an interesting one
because obviously
like i've met them both and paddy's
actually a really big lightweight like
actually when you meet him you're like
wow you make lightweight um
and uh
i i wondered if you thought that that
would be a fight worth making
it's not even way for conversation
because it's not happening it will never
happen whether dana's never gonna let
him silence the ufc this is never gonna
lie it's like when people talk about
connor fighting party one day so you're
not gonna happen yeah yeah i get you i
get you bit of fun bit of fun nothing
more speaking of which um
before i end i do want to talk to you a
little bit more about the fact that
you're in the game
why does that live appeal on the back
that's the city skyline yep how cool is
that right yeah hang on can i do a
screen shot on this show
hang on guys
i'll send you a really good picture of
it i promise okay and also uh we've got
another one with you
uh paddy and uh tom so all the boys are
from uh ufc london and that big event
craig on it yeah so yeah i'm sure
they'll be sending your copy to you as
we speak if i've got one you're getting
one without doubt
come we now listen can you show me what
it looks like or what i will i'll sort
you out after i promise i'll i'll get
them to send everything over thank you
uh but i'm buzzing to see
have i got blonde haired or brown here
uh let's have a look here it looks like
it's your most recent hair
yeah on your lashes i've added like
let's not joke i've had a glow up
recently
i've had botox i've got blondes here
with people white you're
i'm getting composite bonds tomorrow
honestly so yeah the globe is in the
globe package is included for molly
mccann in the new ufc game she's looking
our best we can't wait to play as her
and um what i mean what what is it going
to be
can i literally i've got the playstation
game now
yeah
i'm pretty confident this is all ready
to roll now so yeah
um
what how are you gonna feel like that is
that's i've made it as like
i literally text me girlfriends today
saying
don't do anything don't message me
anything i could just spin me head outs
or do me i don't
because i'm supposed to leave like a
little bit ago yeah
i wonder what color shorts i've got
yeah man you're going to be fighting for
the title in there you're going to be i
don't know
yeah
um
well i'm buzzing for you and if there's
anyone who deserves it in the ufc it's
you so well done i just want to say
thank you you know you fight for us you
you absolutely give everything in the
cage and uh
yeah you can go and play on uh
on your playstation or xbox
okay get everything done get yourself
fed and watered sit yourself down switch
the phone off lad can you send me in
this zoom chat these pictures i'll send
you everything promise me
i promise you i promise
okay that was molly mccann on the pain
game podcast um
one of my favorite fighter interviews
easily such a
people's champion we love her and um i
can't wait to do this again hopefully uh
we'll get you uh round with paddy one
day and we can do a
reaction to the ufc or something like
that that'll be 100
okay that honestly thanks again molly
take care and i'll see you soon no
problem
i want to see these pictures whilst i'm
on this call okay